peu plus
en général nous étions convenus hier je
crois que ce troisième et dernier
entretien rapporte m la république et
les institutions alors la première
question que je voudrais vous poser est
celle-ci le scrutin du 5 décembre aura
en tout cas prouvé que 85% des français
sont définitivement favorable à
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel de même bien
entendu que les candidats des
différentes oppositions même si cela
n'avait pas toujours été leur avis
d'autre part aucun des candidats de ces
oppositions donc pas davantage monsieur
me tran qui sera votre adversaire au
second tour n'a explicitement remise en
cause des institutions
que vous avez créés et auquel vous êtes
attachés par conséquent il ya quelque
chose que l'on comprend la assez mal on
nous dit quelquefois si le général de
gaulle venait à ne pas être élu les
institutions seraient menacés est ce que
l'on comprend mal justement c'est
comment ces institutions
pourraient être menacés par des gens qui
ne les remettent pas en cause
des institutions une constitution
c'est une enveloppe
la question est de savoir ce qui est
dedans
nous avons fait j'ai proposé au pays de
faire la constitution de 58
après les drames que vous savez
et dans l'intention que d'ailleurs je
vais annoncer de la façon la plus
formelle est la plus publique de mettre
un terme au régime des partis
il s'agissait d'empêcher que la
république l'état
fut comme il le tête avant à la
discrétion des parties
et c'est dans cet esprit que la
constitution a été fait et c'est dans
cet esprit que je les proposer au peuple
qui l'a approuvé je suis sûr qu'il l'a
prouvé dans cet esprit
alors si malgré leur enveloppe
malgré les termes
malgré l'esprit de ce qui a été voté en
58 les parties seraient on part des
institutions de la république de l'état
alors évidemment rien ne vaut plus
on a fait des confessionnaux c'est pour
tâcher de repousser le diable mais si le
diable est dans le confessionnal
alors ça change tout
or ce qui est en train d'être essayé
c'est par ledit tour de l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel
or en l'état à la discrétion des parties
car comment on peut marcher la
constitution de 58 y comment marche tu
es et marchait très bien je crois depuis
sept ans
elle marche grâce à un chef d'état qui
n'appartient pas au parti qui n'est pas
déléguer par plusieurs partis ni même la
plus forte raison par tout ce
qui est là pour le pays qui a été
désigné sans doute par les événements
mais qui en outre répond quelque chose
qui commun tous les français pas dessus
les parties et quel est leur intérêt
commun leur intérêt national
c'est comme ça que la constitution
marche depuis 58 si à la place de ce
chef d'état qui est fait pour empêcher
que la république ne ratant va la
discrétion des partis on met un chef
d'état qui n'est que l'émanation des
parties alors je vous le répète on
n'aura rien fait du tout et tout ce
qu'on aura écrit dans la constitution ne
changera rien n'a rien on ne reviendra à
ceux qui étaient qu'avant avec peut-être
quelques formes légèrement différente
mais on ne reviendra au gouvernement si
tant est qu'on puisse l'appeler comme ça
des parties et ce serait j'en suis sûr
comme j'en ai toujours été sur une
catastrophe nationale
général votre adversaire du second tour
monsieur françois-mitterand se présente
comme le candidat unique de la gauche et
de fait il est le candidat du parti
communiste du parti socialiste du parti
radical qui en 1936 formé à eux trois le
front populaire mais de votre côté
vos adversaires de droite nous ont
souvent reproché d'avoir fait en matière
de décolonisation par exemple une
politique de gauche et de faire encore
aujourd'hui en matière de politique
étrangère une politique de gauche je
sais bien que les notions de gauche et
droite sont de plus en plus floue et
entremêlés dans la politique française
néanmoins et peut-être justement pour
cela j'aimerais que vous précisiez la
façon dont vous les entendez dont
voulait conserver ces notions de gauche
et de droite
la france c'est tout à la fois c'est
tous les français
qui est pas la gauche la france c'est
pas la droite la france
naturellement les français comme de tout
temps ils ont tu
as entre temps ne quoi il y à l'éternel
courant du mouvement
qui va aux réformes qui va au changement
qui est naturellement nécessaire et puis
ya aussi un courant de l'ordre la règle
de la tradition qui est aussi nécessaire
si direct ça qu'on fait la france
prétend de faire la france avec une
faction
c'est une erreur grave
et prétendre représenter un frein
au nord d'une fraction
cela c'est une erreur nationale 1 par
donna
vous me dites à droite on dit vous
faites une politique de gauche
au dehors à gauche du reste vous c'est
bien on dit de growl c il est là pour la
droite pour les monopoles quand je ne
sais pas quoi le fait que les partisans
de droite il est partisan de gauche
me déclare que j'appartiens à l'autre
côté prouve
précisément ce que je vous dis c'est à
dire que maintenant comme toujours je ne
suis pas d'un côté je ne suis pas de
l'aude je suis pour la france
il y a pour ce qui est de la france qui
se passe dans une maison
la maîtresse de maison la ménagère
elle veut avoir un aspirateur d'avoir un
frigidaire
elle veut avoir une machine à laver
et même si c'est possible qu'on ait une
tôt
ça c'est le mouvement
en même temps elle veut pas que son mari
saïb embaucher tout pas que les gars on
met les pieds sur la table et que les
fines en attente pas la nuit
sachez landre
et la busnes hager veut le progrès mais
je veux pas la pagaille
et bien c'est vrai aussi pour la france
il faut le progrès il faut pas la
pagaille
or le régime des partis sénat payal
évidemment on l'a vécu
avant la première guerre mondiale
pendant longtemps
ça allait cahin caha à ce moment là on
risque pas grand chose à l'intérieur en
études très riche je parle quand tous
les français bien entendu il s'en faut
mais je vous parle de l'ensemble de ce
qu'on appelait à satiété est très riche
il y avait 2 3% et de la monnaie or les
placements à l'étranger ainsi de suite
on restait là sous la protection des
douanes et on vivait comme ça
l'intérieur confortablement et en
acquitte xt la belle époque bien sûr on
se transformait pas on évolue et
d'autre venez les grands pays
industriels comme l'allemagne
l'angleterre qui avait commencé avant
tout le monde les etats-unis qui avaient
entrepris leur essor nous nous restions
qu'un cas comme nous étions
et puis un euro dehors on risque pas
grand chose non plus bien sûr il y avait
la menace allemande à l'horizon pour le
kazoo mais y'avait l'alliance russes
aient pu apprécier l'entente cordiale
enfin ça allait comme ça
alors il désastre de 14
auquel des astres initial auquel nous
allons échapper par une chance inouïe
par un sursaut du time for national qui
nous a permis de nous en tirer dieu
c'est d'ailleurs avec quelle perte est
encore de nous en tirer
en 14 15 grâce au pouvoir personnel du
père geof et puis en 17/18 à la fin où
cette venelle à matic et infiniment
grave de nouveau grâce au pouvoir
personnel de clemenceau mais dans
l'intervalle
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient fait les
parties il est fait rien ils reversaient
les ministères comme à leur habitude ils
renversaient le mystère visuel ni plus
le premier minister brillant fill 2e
mystère brillant et puis de mystère
ribot et puis lui sert pas lever et
aller donc presse qui faisait les
parties
entre les deux guerres après qu'on a eus
liquide et clemenceau que les parties
ricky dee clemenceau il ya eu alors ce
qu'on sait c'est à dire un régime de
médiocrité un régime d'impuissance ou le
désastre se dessiner à l'horizon sont
confiants réalité rien pour l'empêcher
entre monsieur clemenceau monsieur paul
reynaud c'est à dire de 1920 à 1940
or on a eu 47 ministère à 20 ans aulas
le régime des partis alors naturellement
n'était battu grazay en 40 on avait rien
pas de pareils d'été par les parties on
n'avait pas les armes nécessaires
vous me parlez d'un candidat
actuellement du front populaire est là
moi j'ai connu front populaire je vous
dirais même qu à cette époque là c'était
en 1936
j'avais quelques idées sur la nécessité
de rénover notre défense nationale je
crois bien que les experts l'expérience
a prouvé que si on m'avait écouté on
aurait évité le désastre et on aurait
vraiment tuer d'entreprise d'hitler dans
l'oeuf avant même qu'elle n'ait pu
s'étendre enfin j'espérais un peu que ce
nous venons du front populaire qui nous
paraissait être la nouveauté la réforme
et cetera allait effectivement s'emparer
aussi de la défense ah ben il m'a fallu
bien déchanter et finalement le régime
du front populaire la majorité et front
populaire la chambre du front populaire
le gouvernement du front populaire ça a
fini par le désastre de sedan
l'abdication de la république et la
capitulation devant les nids
alors je reste j'ai hâte de vous dire
que si au lieu d'être ce gouvernement du
front populaire
c'est-à-dire des partis du front
populaire ç'avait été le gouvernement
des autres partis des partis
conservateurs ça aurait été vraiment
exactement la même chose
les partis ne peuvent pas conduire la
france c'est trop dur et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs après mon retour en 45 quand
les partis on repart tous contre moi
bien entendu watts parties n'ont pu rien
fait du tout excepté 23 crise
ministérielle non j'ai parlé samedi
dernier et puis c'est tout alors vous me
dites le personnage que dans le komo
cité est le candidat de la gauche ne
pollue tout il était aussi du reste
candidat de la droite je vous l'apprends
pas il est le candidat des partis voilà
la vérité car tous les partis sont
d'accord pour que de bol s'en aillent là
fut réellement car de boules une fois au
loin
ils en reprennent leur jeu et leur
régime qu'on aime l'auraient obligé de
passer par le détour de l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel c'est à dire de la désignation
de l'un d'entre eux le rhum à la
présidence de la république ce qui fait
qu'on nous reviendrons directement au
régime que nous avons connue et qui nous
a coûté dieu sait combien
voilà ce que je peux vous dire qu'en
général je voudrais maintenant vous
poser une question qui se divisant en
deux sous questions premièrement on vous
accuse depuis longtemps et plus
particulièrement ces derniers temps
d'avoir établi de faire régner sur la
france un pouvoir personnel et
deuxièmement votre adversaire du
dimanche 19 a déclaré l'autre jour que
si vous étiez élu le dimanche 19 d'une
part pour punir les français de ne pas
vous avoir élu le dimanche 5 et d'autre
part pour juguler vos adversaires
politiques vous donneriez un tour de vis
à nos libertés ce que vous pourriez vous
général répondre sur ces deux questions
le pouvoir personnel et le tour de l'iss
une fois plus je répondrai que sur le
pouvoir personnel quand quelqu'un des
responsabilités ce qui est mon cas à
cause de l'histoire et aussi à cause du
fait que je suis là et que je suis là de
par la volonté du peuple jusqu'à présent
alors naturellement mise à des
responsabilités et je voudrais croire
qu'elles sont lourdes il faut qu'il les
porte lui-même pourquoi ils
dépasseraient à d'autres mais je suis
pas tout seul bien sûr j'ai un
gouvernement j'en ai lu tueuse
successivement pendant le septennat
c'est pas beaucoup par rapport à
d'autres régimes enfin c'est tout de
même des ministres et il vous prétoires
que je fais pas tout dur elle se posait
pas il ya un par le parlement qui a été
élu par le peuple différé loi et puis
c'est lui qui les fait les lois lé
parlement c'est pas moi alors voilà ce
que c'est que le pouvoir personnel ce
sont des expressions
on peut employer comme ça par démagogie
mais qui en réalité sont de mauvaise foi
voilà la vérité vient d'ailleurs et un
très bon nous on a dit un dictateur on
n'a jamais vu un dictateur en ballottage
alors parlons de libertés publiques ou
sur les libertés publiques j'ai
détruites c'est moi qui lui ai rendu je
les ai rendu quand je suis rentré en
france 144 me rends tous qu il y en
avait eu bon pourquoi y en avait plus
parce que les parties avaient capitulé
dans les mains de pétain et des
allemands à l'époque où il fallait pas
enfin mme auger rendu la liberté
publique
j'ai pas détruite pendant le temps que
j'étais là et puis sept ans que je suis
là je parle et rit des libertés
publiques la liberté de la presse est ce
qu'elle existe pas presque toute la
presse mme est hostile et je n'empêche
pas et la liberté syndicale est-ce que
je n'empêche pas le moins du monde bien
au contraire je fais tout pour essayer
d' associer les syndicats ou
développement commun de la france et
quels autres libertés jld de la liberté
de vote va vous le voyez bien ce qui se
passe
le 1er juin
1958 j'étais revenu la veille
c'est la veille que j'avais reçu
l'investiture j'étais devenu le
président du conseil avant d'être
président de la république
j'irai qu'a pris la liberté de la presse
que le régime des partis les jours
d'avant parce qu'ils mourraient peur
avait supprimé j'ai supprimé la censure
j'ai jamais rétabli voilà la réalité
alors il faudrait que les plaisanteries
soit plus courte parce que sont les
meilleurs qui sont les plus courtes mais
quand elles sont très longs vols sont en
mauvais rêve des plaisanteries mon
général je voudrais maintenant vous
poser une dernière question à la suite
de votre allocution du 4 novembre là où
vous avez annoncé aux français que vous
aviez décidé de vous porter candidat à
la présidence de la république à nouveau
on a beaucoup dit et beaucoup répété que
vous nous aviez placée devant une
alternative
qui pouvait s'exprimer de la façon
suivante moi ou le chaos avec cette
variante moi ou le néant certes personne
ne prétendait que c'était exactement 10
dans la dans la lettre du texte mais
beaucoup le voyaient de façon assez
claire dans l'esprit de ce texte
évidemment interprété cela comme une
sorte de condamnation implicite des
institutions si elle n'était pas capable
de fonctionner après vous mais surtout
c'est ce qui était peut-être encore
peut-être plus grave comme une preuve de
défiance vis-à-vis de votre entourage
vous nous voyez personne capable
d'assurer un jour votre succession alors
je crois qu'il est qu'il est nécessaire
pour terminer que vous expliquiez sur
ces points ou même sur ces deux points
comme vous l'avez remarqué je n'ai pas
dis moi et je n'ai pas ni le chaos
j'ai dit et je répète ceci
s'il devait arriver
le 19 décembre
que le peuple français
décida des cartes et de goût
c'est à dire
tranchons le mot
de renier ce qui est une partie de son
histoire
et je le crois excusez moi encore
aujourd'hui or le moment une nécessité
nationale
si le peuple français en décider ainsi
je suis convaincu que le régime des
partis en revenant ainsi que je lui ai
expliqué tout à l'heure ce serait pour
le pays un immense malheur
j'ai dit pourquoi et je ne vois pas
encore une fois qu'il puisse en être
autrement dès lors que moi partie ce que
nous savons
les fractions que nous savons
reviendrait les maîtres de l'état et de
la république
alors on dit ben oui mais votre
succession parce que ça pourra pas durer
toujours
je suis le premier à savoir que ça
durera pas toujours
eh bien ma succession pour le moment
n'est pas ouverte en moi naturellement
que le peuple français encore une fois
louvre lui même dimanche prochain
sinon elle n'est plus ouverte et par
conséquent pour un temps dont je
n'apprécie pas la durée
il sera possible à l'actuel président de
la république de le demain d'un
naturellement un jour viendra plus tôt
ou un peu plus tard où ce ne sera plus
le cas
et où de gaulle disparaître sa
succession sera donc ouverte
que se produire at il alors que doit
qu'il se produit
le même débat que nous vivons
aujourd'hui se reproduira alors
si alors le peuple français
revient
au même combinaison
au même système
au même fraction dont nous avons
longuement parlé tout à l'heure c'est à
dire au régime des partis ça n'aura été
que reculer pour moins bien sauter
si au contraire
le peuple français demeure au moment de
l'élection de mon successeur
fidèle à la ligne qu'il a tracée à mon
appel
et qui est celle d'un chef de l'état qui
n'appartient à personne
excepté à la france et qui n'est là pour
servir personne
excepté la france et les français
ce personnage là ce n'est pas le même
que celui dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
ce personnage là étant accompagné de
tous ceux et ils sont nombreux
qui pensent d'eux mêmes et de tout ce
qui peut être d'ici là viendront se
joindre à eux
alors je crois que l'avenir a les plus
grandes chances d'être assuré
bien sûr mon successeur ne fera pas
comme moi il n'y aura pas comme j'ai dit
un certain certains occasion la même
équation personnelle il fera comme une
fois il fera comme il voudra
il fera pas pareil
mais pour l'essentiel
qui est d'un appartenir encore une fois
qu'on pays tout entier
il pourra le faire et s'il le fait je
crois que la république doit durer et la
france aussi
la question sûrs
françaises français vous avez insisté à
notre dialogue
et bien c'est votre affaire ce qui va se
passer dimanche et ce qui se passera
plus tard
je n'ai jamais servi que votre affaire
et
aujourd'hui et demain je ne suis là que
pour cela
après moi il vous appartient
de suivre la même ligne que nous avons
tracée ensemble depuis 1958 et de la
suivre franchement
cela vous appartient et sa partie en
particulier à vous jeunes français
qui n'avait pas encore été mêlé à tout
ça je parle des mi'kmaq dont nous avons
longuement parlé tout à l'heure et donc
je souhaite ardemment que vous vous en
ayez pas que vous considériez votre
chose qui le pays tout entier la france
et que vous marchiez droit comme je
crois j'ai marché droit à la tête de la
république est de la france depuis
quelques 25 ans
voilà ce que je peux dire
du reste
quoi qu'il arrive
j'aurai rempli
mon destin j'aurai fait mon service
mais si j'ai été assez heureux pour
rendre à la france ce service là d'avoir
fait avec elle mise en route avec elle
et c'est accepter pareille un régime
nouveau un régime d'action un régime de
réalisation un régime de cohésion alors
j'aurai rempli ma vie
voilà ce que je peux vous dire qu'en
général je vous remercie d'avoir répondu
ces trois soirs aux questions que je
vous ai posé aux questions que je crois
beaucoup de français aurait voulu
pouvoir vous poser eux-mêmes oh je ne me
fais pas d'illusion dira il n'a pas posé
toutes les questions qu'il aurait dû
poser enfin je crois sincèrement en
toute conscience que j'ai posées les
principales et que vous y avez répondu
mon général je vous remercie et bien
quand le ch vous remercie monnaie
[Musique]